je veux évidemment rappeler les cinq les
cinq crises qui vont toucher notre pays
et pour lequel il s'est intérieur doit
prévoir des moyens politiques après les
avoir défini c'est le cas du rapport
annexé assez long que nous avons proposé
et puis des moyens budgétaires qui
accompagnent ces objectifs politiques
d'abord il y a évidemment une crise
que nous pourrions considérer comme
étant une crise d'ordre public on l'a vu
dans les manifestations précédentes les
gilets jaunes en son exemple premier
c'est fini les manifestations à la papa
c'est fini le fait que nous puissions
tous
considérer que nous connaissons par
avance qui va manifester avec des
services d'ordre de syndicats organisés
dans une seule ville de France nous
devons désormais faire face à des
manifestations spontanées numériques peu
prévisible et l'ordre public c'est un
métier ce n'est pas un métier que peut
faire n'importe quelle policier
n'importe quel gendarme c'est un métier
qui connaît une formation spécifique
d'où notamment la recréation de 15
unités de force mobile supplémentaires
je rappelle que
11 pardon unités supplémentaire je
rappelle que 15 avait été supprimé dans
les 20 dernières années nous recréons
pour la première fois cette escadron de
gendarmerie mobile 4 compagnies de CRS
pourquoi d'ailleurs cette Escada mobile
parce qu'il y a des crises dans des
crises notamment dans les crises
ultramarines que nous pouvons connaître
vous savez bien que c'est l'apanage des
gendarmes extrêmement souvent que d'être
envoyé sur les territoires en crise
l'organisation des référendums en
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'était le cas
l'hiver dernier évidemment des sujets
qui se posent à Mayotte ou en Guyane
nous en reparlerons sans doute
avec la crise de l'ordre public n'est
deuxième crise qu'elle a crise cyber qui
est l'objet d'ailleurs essentiel des
crédits que nous vous demandons puisque
sur les 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires plus de la moitié sont
pour le cyber et pour le numérique au
ministère de l'intérieur soit pour
simplifier la vie des policiers des
gendarmes aux agents préfecture
eux-mêmes une faire l'impôt à la source
finalement au ministère de l'Intérieur
simplifier un centre de procédure qui
aujourd'hui démobilisent nos agents qui
me disent qu'ils sont pris par la
paperasse ou par les difficultés de
discussion avec les citoyens ou avec la
justice mais bien sûr et surtout si
j'ose dire lutter contre la menace
nouvelle qui est la menace du cyber
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié notamment
des escroqueries que nous connaissons
sont déjà des esprits cyber et nous
savons que demain
la crise que nous allons connaître cyber
va toucher de manière considérable le
secret des correspondances ces activités
économiques des plus petites PME de vos
circonscriptions les hôpitaux publics
que bien évidemment que l'attentat
lui-même ne sera sans doute plus celui
qui sera caractér commencer par un homme
qui rentre avec une kalachnikov dans une
salle de spectacle même si évidemment ce
sujet peut toujours arriver mais que ce
sera un drone chargé d'explosif qui ira
sur une foule en même temps que les feux
rouges de la capitale pour être attaqué
par une attaque cyber ainsi que les
hôpitaux prévus dans le plan blanc et là
ce n'est pas quelques dizaines ou
quelques centaines de morts mais
potentiellement des milliers de morts au
sens littéral du terme bien évidemment
auquel nous devons nous préparer et
c'est pour ça que les les crises que
nous connaissons dans le monde militaire
parce que les attaques de drone armés
existent dans les opérations extérieures
aujourd'hui vont évidemment s'importer
dans le monde de la politique de la
sécurité intérieure et nous devons voir
comment nous pouvons répondre à cette
crise terroriste nouvelle ces menaces
nouvelles et le cyber évidemment en fait
particulier en partie dans dans ce que
désormais nous appelons la guerre
hybride et qui a connu son son arrivée
si j'ose dire pour les Français pendant
le conflit
ukrainien après la crise d'entreprise
après la crise cyber nous n'avons
évidemment une crise de sécurité civile
du réchauffement climatique les les feux
de cet été ont démontré à quel point le
réchauffement climatique n'ont pas qu'il
en soit particulièrement responsable a
priori mais qu'il donne les conditions
évidemment de la diffusion des
intempéries que nous connaissons et
notamment des feux fait que nous avons
besoin de renforcer de manière
absolument considérable nos moyens de
sécurité civile songez que la moitié des
feux de cet été au lieu au nord de la
Loire et non plus simplement c'est j'ose
dire dans les départements que nous
connaissions habitués au feu de forêt la
Corse les Vars les Bouches-du-Rhône les
Alpes-Maritimes lorsque le Jura est
concerné lorsque la Bretagne connaît des
milliers d'hectares qui brûlent lorsque
la Maine-et-Loire connaît des milliers
d'hectares qui brûlent cet été nous
devons adapter nos systèmes aériens nos
systèmes d'intervention évidemment qui
coûte beaucoup d'argent dont la locmi
d'ailleurs avant même les annonces du
président de la République qui seront
complétés monsieur président pendant le
débat budgétaire et le débat de la de la
lotm être au rendez-vous de cette crise
de sécurité civile qui fait naître aussi
un quinquennat qui n'a connu les pires
intempéries de notre histoire récente
nous avons commencé le quinquennat
précédent par Irma à Saint-Martin nous
l'avons quasiment terminé avec la
Vésubie et la Roya
à la fin du quinquennat on va bien que
indépendamment des feux des questions
relevant du réchauffement climatique et
l'intervention du ministère de
l'Intérieur puisque dans la
responsabilité en moyenne technologique
et en moyenne technique et humains et
très important après la crise d'ordre
public après la crise cyber après la
crise de sécurité civile je veux
évidemment souligner l'importance de la
lutte contre la délinquance les
nouvelles formes de délinquance qui sont
aujourd'hui au rendez-vous de notre
constat et qui vont s'aggraver demain en
complément d'ailleurs de la de la crise
cyber les points de Deal demain seront
en très grande partie numérique nous
aurons à saisir des actifs financiers ce
que nous ne pouvons pas faire c'est
d'ailleurs le principe même d'ailleurs
d'un des articles de loi de de cette loc
et nous ne pouvons pas
ignorer que une grande partie de
l'argent sale désormais circule de
manière numérique et que les
dispositions technologiques comme la
crypto ou les moyens
de téléphonique moderne nous empêche que
les écoutes téléphoniques classiques les
moyens de présence sur la voie publique
ont considérablement changé notre
intervention et je ne parle même pas de
la voiture autonome qui dans 7 ou 8 ans
on va complètement changer la façon dont
les motards par exemple feront des
contrôles autoroutiers évidemment il
faut réfléchir à tous à tous ce sujet
d'où d'ailleurs des moyens extrêmement
importants mis en formation initiaux et
continue dans ce texte de loi on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler et il y a un
objectif simple que le doublement de la
présence de la voie publique et je crois
que nous détaillons très largement
comment on atteint ce doublement de la
présence sur la voie publique à la fois
en faisant des réformes internes au
ministères de l'Intérieur je pense aussi
que l'horaire en augmentant les
effectifs 8500 policiers gendarmes et
agents préfecture demandés dans ce texte
de loi la recréation parlant des 200
brigades de gendarmerie apprendre
supprimer 500 en 30 ans démontrent je
crois ce sujet de présence de voie
publique on a l'occasion d'en reparler
c'est vraiment l'objet sans doute
principal du rapport indexé que vous
avez eu dans votre article premier et
puis cinquièmement j'en terminerai
peut-être pas là une crise de
l'investigation qu'il a fait le lien
avec le travail que fait le mistral
justice qui aura l'occasion de présenter
un texte de procédure pénale et de code
pénale il n'appartient pas au ministère
de l'Intérieur de présenter évidemment
des textes qui relèvent du ministre de
la justice mais l'investigation la façon
dont on qualifie les officiers de
préjudiciaires les assistantes d'enquête
recréés qui sont des formes de greffiers
de de police que mes dégrafiés de
justice va de pair évidemment avec les
difficultés que nous connaissons toutes
et tous puisque nous avons mis de plus
en plus de personnes sur la voie
publique dans le quinquennat précédent
il y a à peu près une vingtaine de pour
cent de trafiquants de délinquant
interpellé de manière supplémentaire
mais il faut évidemment faire des
enquêtes il faut évidemment les produire
il faut les présenter à la justice et
dans la réponse pénale qui nous paraît
parfois décevante il y a beaucoup de
travail incomplet des services du
ministère de l'intérieur par manque de
PJ vous le savez bien dans chacun de vos